returning to switzerland now as i say
the votes being counted
and scrutinized very closely
by those three people sitting there this
is a
ballot a second round ballot to try to
form an
interim government in libya another step
on the road
towards reconciliation in a country that
was torn apart by war
for well most of the past decade as the
votes
are counted and verified we'll check in
with james baze who's our diplomatic
editor
watching from you and headquarters in
new york as they all are there i suspect
james
yeah and i think that might be the last
vote he showed them he's divided them
into two
two different piles kamal and he's now
going to count i guess the two piles
these are piles each of the piles for
two different slates of candidate
uh to be the presidency council of libya
the new
uh the new interim government of libya
which is going to be announced in the
next
few moments uh they had um a
group of electors 75 electors
that the un chose representative they
said of the people
of libya that have been carrying out
this political dialogue
they produced and have before them four
different slates
of people who could be on this
presidency council they had a first vote
uh between those different four slates
uh they
reduced it to two and so we're now going
through those two
final slates to decide which of the two
slates
uh is going to be the one that is going
to be the new interim government
of libya only a temporary government
because this is a government to take
libya
through the next few months ahead of a
proper election election where the
people of libya rather than delegates
are going to decide
uh a one-person one-vote election
planned by the united nations and the
libyan authorities at the end of the
year
as you can see they are trying to do
this in a way that means there can be no
dispute
and various um observers at the front
watching the results
and what will happen shortly once they
have lodged those results is they will
be announced to all of us
and then you're going to hear the person
who's been leading this process
the un's acting special envoy stephanie
williams is going to speak about it
i can tell you a lot of atmosphere
expectation here at the united
nations headquarters uh it's relatively
early in the morning here but people are
following this
extremely closely they're um they think
it could be a very
optimistic and important moment at the
same time
they are careful um not to be over
optimistic
because in some ways we've been here
before
five years ago there was an agreement in
morocco in a place called
skirat that came up with an interim
government and that just became
another um source of power between
various other power centers that existed
in libya just caused more confusion
and eventually more violence so
this we're taking nothing for granted
here but
certainly of all the conflicts that the
un is involved in all the peace
processes around the world
this is the one that the un and the
secretary general antonio guterres
are most hopeful about the fact that
they can bring
um an end to the conflict in libya and
the timing is really amazing
it's almost exactly 10 years since the
start
of the uprising uh in libya
which of course led to the downfall of
of
colonel gaddafi and he he he um
he in 2011 it was later in the summer
that he finally was toppled from tripoli
and eventually um he was uh killed in
cert
yeah james i think we see stephanie
williams actually uh maybe just going
over some notes and uh
and approaching at the moment so i'll
leave you there just for now
uh in fact here she comes stephanie
williams is going to
uh address the people in geneva there
and the rest of the world
to find out about the results of these
uh well this ballot as i said a second
round ballot
uh for the libyan interim government
un-led process which is now into some of
its final stages here
as they try to as james saying 10 years
almost to the day after
the uprising in libya looks like they're
still organizing a few
uh things uh his
positions of prime minister and as james
was saying a presidency
council being decided today
to bring some sort of stability to libya
right now and then moving towards the
idea of a full
as james said one person one ballot vote
later
in the year baby steps all the way but
this
is definitely positive signs that we're
seeing coming out of geneva
still taking their time there so i might
just check in with james again james i
think you're watching the same things i
am so do jump in whenever you want but
can i just check in what you were saying
about presidency council exactly what
does that mean
well that they're going to be the
governing body now in libya
and there's going to be a prime minister
as part of that presidency council and
the chair of the council i suppose
effectively a president
um but it's a joint presidency council
rather than one
single person but there will be one
person who presides
over uh the country uh as the the chair
of that presidency council
uh this is the formula the the un has
chosen
um for this short term government this
interim government for libya
other important things taking place at
the same time
there is still a joint military
commission which is meeting as we speak
in cert right now remember there is a
ceasefire in place in libya and they
want to try and build
on that ceasefire and there's also
supposed to be and we've already had one
deadline passed
uh foreign fighters and foreign um for
foreign
for the new executive authority
there were 73 ballots
that were cast there was one abstention
and there were zero uh
ballots that were that were somehow not
not correct or or spoiled
the winning
tickets that won 39
votes for the presidency
of the presidency council mr muhammad
yunus and menifee
a
member of the presidency councilman
member of the presidency council mr musa
alconi
member of the presidency council mr
abdullah al-lafi
[Applause]
and the prime minister designate mr
abdulhamid daba
[Applause]
the runner-up list received 34 votes
and the president's the candidate for
the president
was mr aguila saleh
the member of the presidency council is
mr osama joueli
other member of the presidency council
was mr
abdullah majid nasser
and the prime minister candidate was
fatiga
on behalf of the yes
[Applause]
on behalf of the united nations i am
pleased
to witness this historic moment
the important
the importance of the decision that you
have taken here today will grow
with the passage of time
in the collective memory of the libyan
people
this process your process
has come a long way from when we first
convened you virtually in october
of last year
you overcame your differences your
divisions
and the many challenges you have faced
during this difficult
but fruitful journey in the interests of
your country
and of the libyan people you understood
the burden of your responsibility
and the immense value of your
contributions
you fulfilled your commitments before
your constituencies
your compatriots will remember for many
years to come
this national conscientiousness you have
so ably
demonstrated our bet
was that you would be able to build a
truly libyan-owned solution
and that is what you have done
the international community can only
validate
and reinforce your decisions and will be
watching
those you have selected to
make sure they truly go back to the
libyan
people on december 24th of this year
to democratically elect libya's
representatives
and political leadership as they have
pledged to do
so before you in word and in writing
this is a solemn obligation and one
that the new executive must fulfill
the challenges are not behind you
the prime minister designate must
within a period not to exceed 21 days
form his cabinet and present its work
program along with all of the outcomes
of the libyan political dialogue forum
to the house of representatives
for full endorsement and to grant
confidence
within a period also not to succeed
21 days from the date of submission to
the parliament
if confidence is not granted the matter
shall be decided by the lpdf
the new executive unified authority
should commit to translating the spirit
and
principles of the road map with actions
and deeds first
i call on them to respect and translate
the unity
and inclusivity which you have built
in this form in the formation of a
government
that is based on merit confidence
and which is representative of all
libyans
including youth cultural components
and women they have already committed
to ensuring that women will hold at
least 30 percent
of the senior executive positions
second urgent action
is needed to uphold the election date of
24
december which will require
that the new government must
extend its full support to the
to the h-neck
and to the concerned institutions to
finalize
the necessary constitutional
arrangements for the holding of the
elections
in line with their responsibilities and
the timeline that has been
set out in the tunis roadmap
third the new
unified executive must as stipulated in
the roadmap
launch a comprehensive national
reconciliation process
based on the principles of transitional
justice
and promoting the culture of amnesty and
tolerance
in parallel with truth seeking and
reparation
fourth the new unified executive must
fully support
and implement the ceasefire agreement
this will require bold and determined
action
on the part of the new government in
support of the five plus five
joint military commission in particular
for the reopening of the coastal road
and the withdrawal
of all foreign forces and mercenaries
the reopening of the coastal road will
also be critical for the delivery of
basic services
and to ensure free movement of goods and
people
which is essential to restore the
prosperity
of a united libya
fifth the new executive must
tackle libya's economic crisis and the
dire living conditions
faced by libyan citizens
since the oil blockade was lifted in
september of 2020
important progress has been achieved to
enact
the economic reforms needed to create a
more equitable
and durable economic arrangement for
libya's oil revenues
the reactivation of the central bank of
libya board of governors
the unification of the exchange rate
the progress and the financial review of
both
branches of the central bank and the
launch of the comprehensive audit of the
libyan investment authority
on the 11th of january have been setting
the stage for the reunification of
libya's
economic and financial institutions and
policies
and increasing the integrity and
performance
of libya's sovereign wealth
as we were gathering in switzerland
libya's first unified national budget
since 2014
was agreed and is awaiting promulgation
by the current
presidency council as stipulated in the
road map
the current presidency council and
government
should continue to work in a caretaker
capacity
until the endorsement by the house of
representatives
of the new temporary unified executive
and should ensure that a peaceful
transition
and a constructive handover take place
without delay and in the interests of
the country
all parallel authorities should be
considered null and void
the libyan political dialogue forum has
not completed its task
you have a critical role to play in the
months ahead
as the custodians and monitors
of the roadmap which you adopted in
tunis
you have demonstrated your political
strength
throughout this process and you must
continue to work
in the same spirit to ensure that the
aspirations
and clear demands of the libyan people
do not remain
unfulfilled and unanswered you must hold
stephanie williams is the acting u.n
envoy to libya announcing the results of
a ballot today the second ballot
in switzerland to elect what we now have
a
libyan interim government 73 ballots
cast 39-34 it was in the
end we will start uh to discuss this
with james bayes our diplomatic
editor watching from un headquarters in
new york i'm going to talk james to a
correspondent in libya shortly about the
the details about some of the people
we've heard about
can you take us through the process of
what's happened
well the key thing is that libya now has
a new
government a brand new government agreed
by
a representative group of libyans
brought together
by the united nations after a ballot of
that group
this uh this forum that they brought
together uh they have elected
uh uh as people a four-person presidency
council that's supposed to guide libya
to elections uh at the end of the year
so a very
optimistic moment for libya but you've
got to remember that we have been here
before the scherat agreement of 2015
came up with an interim government and
it got nowhere at all so we have a new
government
is everyone going to accept its
authority i think is
question number one and there are other
problems facing libya as well
uh there is a ceasefire in place which
is very good news but
the international community and the u.n
security council are worried about the
foreign presence in libya and foreign
meddling in libya already one deadline
has passed for all foreign forces
to leave libya a joint military
commission is meeting right now a
separate diplomatic process
inside libya in cert and it i believe is
going to come up with a new deadline
uh the un security council be forced
into action soon because
uh they will have to um approve the
monitoring mission
that the u.n secretary general that
they've asked the u.n secretary general
to set
up and i'm hearing that an initial group
of monitors probably
not more than a dozen will be dispatched
to plan
that monitoring mission to keep the
ceasefire holding
until the election uh stephanie williams
the acting special
uh representative is going to retire she
has achieved a great deal as the
stand-in remember the u.n hasn't had
a proper envoy in libya for about a year
after gassan salame
who set out this plan retired because of
ill health and then there's been
a squabbling among the u.n security
council about who's going to get the job
and
they've now found a veteran u.n official
uh
jan kubis who previously has been the
un's man in afghanistan in iraq
and in lebanon so he will pick this up
and try and push it through
to elections it's a very optimistic
moment but there are many many hurdles
ahead kamal okay james stay there for me
if you would please i want to get a
little more detail with malek trainer
in tripoli as i look at this list malik
names
like musa alconi abdul hamid
the baba these are not familiar names to
us maybe you can tell us a little bit
more about their backgrounds
uh yeah sure well muhammad al-munfie who
is now
going to be the head of the presidential
council is a former
uh ambassador uh of libya to greece
uh he but he's a lot more low-key than
than than the other list this list of
candidates that have one
are a lot more low-key uh they they're
not very
known as the others are they're much
more the other list was a lot more
controversial
musa alconi who is now the deputy
of of muhammad al-munfie was a former
ambassador to mali
he was also a deputy on in the
presidential council under fire
but he resigned uh shortly after holding
that position
abdullah al-lafi now a member um deputy
to the presidential council was an mp
he's from western libya
and of course abdul hamid baba the new
prime minister of libya
is a successful businessman uh from the
the
the the city of misrata uh he was
also a senior official in the gaddafi
regime
so uh so is that all a good sort of
story
a good sort of mix across the east west
because this has been the issue isn't it
a complete divide across libya does this
cover the bases
i think it does uh i think it does these
aren't really uh
they these the people that have now been
elected these officials
haven't had strong positions with
or against either side so they can
comfortably
come into any city abdulhamid dubaiba
for instance
has visited eastern libya before uh he's
he's known
across a wide variety of libyans as a
successful businessman
and as a a a good manager
uh so i think this uh list of
of of officials uh can comfortably uh
begin to work on a serious
reconciliation process
now of course there's also been some
criticism uh
here in libya on both sides in east and
west
that the u.n has sort of overstepped
their boundaries so
uh whether or not uh you know those in
those with
weapons will adhere to or respect the
results of this uh elections
remains to be seen but for the most part
uh the
legitimate bodies have have said that
they will respect the outcome
uh we heard stephanie williams say that
the next step is for
the uh parliament to to certify
uh uh this new this new government into
power
uh the the the the speaker of the
chipotle-based parliament yesterday
us in a in a in a letter said that he
would accept and respect
uh the results and that he would call
for a session for all
mps to meet and to certify this
government malik trainer and tripoli
thank you just a final word from james
bayes again diplomatic editor
in new york the united nations often
accused of
inaction or having long drawn out
processes which don't get anywhere even
with all the
caution about what's happened today this
has to be seen as some level of success
for the group
yeah i mean i think the um will be
counting this as a success they'll be
they'll be careful i don't think they're
going to be crowing about this
because there have been so many false
dawns in libya in the past
expect a statement from the secretary
general i would expect
in the next hour or so and at some point
when they can agree one expect a
statement from the un security council
i think everyone thinks this is good
news but i don't think anyone
um believes there are not big
difficulties ahead
i think a lot of credit will go to
stephanie williams in this acting role
um who has achieved so much in libya
maybe the time was just right but she is
a diplomat who knows the middle east
well
she knows what happened in the arab
spring it is
now almost exactly it was the 15th of
february that the uprising in libya
started she was a u.s diplomat at the
time not serving in libya but she was
the deputy and
i was acting in charge again uh in the
u.s embassy in bahrain during the arab
spring so she knows what happened in
those heady days
james bayes is our diplomatic editor in
new york we'll hear more from him
in the newshour coming up shortly we
have been
watching uh developments from near
geneva in switzerland
as the un led peace process
for libya reaches the point where a
ballot a second ballot took place today
and as a result of the country now has
an interim
uh government muhammad al-mafi from
eastern libya will become
the president supported by musa alconi
and abdullah lafi
on that presidential council which we
talked about
and abdul hamid the baba will become the
prime minister names that we perhaps not
heard so much of
until now in libya but will become far
more prominent and take such an
important role
as libya tries to find that stability
with an interim government
and eventually move itself towards
one person one vote elections later
in the year